welcome back to prison organization I'm
gonna say the camera never lies but is
that true take a look at this Photograph
it's the winner of a Sony World
photography award but the artist who
created it ended up rejecting his prize
after admitting he made it during using
artificial intelligence well the use of
AI is seemingly everywhere these days
but the Morris used the more debate it
creates just this afternoon a song that
uses AI to clone the voices of Drake and
the weekend to the biggest selling
artists in the world has been removed
from streaming services after singing
criticism from their music company over
copyright laws versus have a listen to
what they normally sound like
I guess we'll never know where Harvard
gets us but seeing my family have it all
took the place of that desire for the
flomas on the wall and really I think I
like who I'm becoming there's times
where I might do it just to do it like
it's nothing
well now here's the AI version of Drake
in the weekend
[Music]
I know well absolutely fascinating well
joining me now is next year at a music
industry Legend and now the chief
executive of tcat or to catch the thief
an anti-piracy business and from Israel
historian and his best-selling author
sapiens Yuval Noah Harari well welcome
to both of you and Nick Stuart great
piece in the telegraph today which you
were quoted about this song and about
that photograph
really I think demonstrating what a
threat AI is to the creative arts my
question for you is how serious do you
think that thread is and should it
really matter or is this in its own way
another form of Art
well the threat is huge we're on the
edge of a precipice and I'm not trying
to be too dramatic here it's come across
so quickly as well that's the point
this the two tracks that you played I
think people need to understand the
original it was done by by Drake in the
weekend the AI generator listens to all
Drake and all weekend and then put
something together that comes out as the
second track you played so it there's no
artist involved it is completely
generated I said here's my question for
you yeah I saw you tapping your fingers
to the AI version spontaneous yeah right
it's a good tune yeah why should we care
why does it matter why couldn't Drake
and we can actually think you know what
this saves us a lot of work okay
two things one is there's a British
copyright law which dates back to 1988
so it's a you could say it's a bit out
of date and it's been tinkered with
the other thing is passing off which is
not actually on the statute book passing
off has been handed down through
precedence through judges and passing
off is what this is which is why it's
been removed exactly but let me ask you
this what if Drake in the weekend like I
said what if they decided to adopt this
technology to save them having to come
up with new songs is that possible could
it be a force for good no artists don't
do that even if it was a big hit it's a
good song well
I know what you're suggesting yeah
artist and I'm sure if Drake was here he
would say and he got very cross about
another track that had been similarly
dealt with artists want to do their own
stuff that's what they're in the game
for we've had situations in the past
with groups who've been doing
rip-offs and samples and all the rest of
it real artists want to do their music I
don't want anybody all right but what
about the photograph which was a
beautiful photograph so good it won an
award before the guy who did it said
well actually AI created this as a lover
of great photography why should we care
if that's been done by artificial
intelligence or by an actual human being
because they've infringed it's taken it
was done from the Getty Library wasn't
it so what they did they went into the
Getty library and they just picked it
again they scraped it all out and up it
came and they scraped it so well so it's
theft basically it's theft yeah okay let
me bring in Hoover I want to start if I
may uh Yuva by playing this is a clip
from Elon Musk talking to Tucker Carlson
on Fox news last night very interesting
what he said
I'm going to start something which you
call truth gbt or
a maximum truth seeking AI
that tries to understand the nature of
the universe and I think this this might
be the best path to Safety in the sense
that an AI that cares about
understanding the universe uh it is
unlikely to annihilate humans because we
are an interesting part of the universe
so evil this came after he said that
actually AI could lead to the end of
humanity as we know it if we allow
because it would be a superior
intelligent Force which if it managed to
break out from Human control could be
the end of it and that reminded me of a
conversation I had with Professor
Stephen Hawking in what was his last
television interview which he said this
is artificial intelligence
going to be the end of us
and if it's not
how do we best work with it
ever since the start of the Industrial
Revolution there have been fears of mass
unemployment as machines replaced humans
instead the demand for goods and
services has risen in line with the
increased capabilities
whether this can continue indefinitely
that's an open question but there is a
greater Danger from artificial
intelligence if we allow it to become
self-designing for then it can improve
itself rapidly and we may lose control
it's a really interesting that Elon Musk
really is now saying what Professor
Hawking told me you're an expert in this
field how worried should we be about
artificial intelligence actually taking
control
we should be very worried because what
we need to understand about AI
artificial intelligence it is the first
tool that can make decisions by itself
all previous inventions in human history
always empowered us they always gave us
more power because the decisions were
always made by humans if you invent a
knife the knife cannot decide whether to
use it to cut salad or to murder
somebody or to save their life in
surgery if you invent an atom bomb
similarly the atom bomb cannot decide
who to attack and when and where AI is
the first technology that can actually
make decisions by itself it can make
decisions about its own usage and
development
nukes cannot make better nukes but AI
can make better and I and also AI can
make and does make decisions about us
increasingly when you apply to a bank to
get a loan you apply to a to get a job
it's an AI making crucial decisions
about your life and we haven't seen
anything yet AI is just making its first
tiny baby steps yeah it's something like
10 years old you know to really think
about it think about it as like this is
the beginning of organic life
4 billion years ago this is the first
amoeba crawling out of the organic soup
can you imagine how Tyrannosaurus Rex
would look like or how Homo sapiens
would look like and what we'll be able
to okay you successfully you
successfully yeah look you successfully
terrified me and probably all my viewers
so how do we save ourselves from the
T-Rex of AI
well first of all it can also of course
be used for good and so far we are still
in control but we don't know for how
many years
and therefore we need to first of all
understand the capabilities of AI and
slow down its deployment to make sure
that we use it wisely and safely you
know the same way that a drug company
cannot just release a new medicine to
the public without going through a very
rigorous safety checks it should be the
same with AI
here's the problem it seems to me which
is it's fine to be well-meaning I mean
Elon Musk I think a lot of what he does
he's a Force for good in many ways you
know he all the stuff he's been involved
with is to try and I think help rather
than damage the planet but this AI
intelligence is going to get in the
hands of some pretty bad people with
some pretty popular regimes and they're
not going to have any qualms about
trying to get the edge over the west or
America or wherever it may be that's
where I see the real danger is it you
know a bit like nuclear weapons getting
into Rogue States hands is that once the
wrong people have control of this then
all hell could break loose
in the hands of the wrong people AI
could be the end of democracy AI could
also be the basis for the worst
totalitarian regimes in human history
because you know dictators always
dreamed about following everybody and
monitoring everybody all the time but
they could never do it because you know
even the Soviet Union you have 200
million Soviet citizens Stalin didn't
have 200 million KGB officers to follow
everybody around all the time and then
to analyze all you need millions of
analysts to analyze all the data you
collect okay AI now it is becoming
possible you don't need human agents to
follow our us around well that was
exciting or sound desk which is two days
old today just crashed so that's why we
went off there a little uh suddenly in
the middle of that debated by AI as my
mother texted me oh my God has AI taken
over which actually was a pretty good
way of looking at it so I'm rejoined
hopefully by our two guests next year is
with me and by you Val in Israel Israel
my apologies for the sudden uh departure
from you there uh technology never works
when you need it yeah I don't think it
is AI but you can never be too sure
um I'll come to you in a moment just
just to round off you were telling me a
story in the break there about Oasis
tell me what what that was about as I'm
sure your viewers know Oasis the
Gallagher brothers broke up okay there
have been talk of reconciliation but at
the moment that's not on the table if
you go on YouTube you will find
something called Isis which is a i s i s
talking about a lost album an AI
generator has made and what's it like
it's it's uncannily good right so if
you're an oasis band why would you not
want that no well the answer is
um yes you would and so but I mean in
terms of bands that have ceased I mean
when people go down the route of trying
to hey I've got a bit of it here I think
and I've just wasted it away
[Music]
I'm gonna use faster let's go go to
u-val uh finally you've all give us end
on some hope here for us all right I I
need to feel more hopeful than than I do
right now because I basically think the
world's gonna end quite soon when these
when Terminator comes real
um do you believe that the planet has
the right people in the right place to
actually stop that happening
I hope so what you we know about
technology that you know you can use the
same technology to build completely
different Societies in the 20th century
some people used uh trains and radio and
electricity to build totalitarian
regimes like the Soviet Union and other
people used exactly the same technology
to build liberal democracies it's the
same with AI and with the Technologies
of the 21st century we still have a
choice about how to employ them I think
that AI is nowhere near its full
potential yeah but also human beings are
nowhere near our full potential we don't
really understand the full potential of
our brains of our minds if we invest for
if for every dollar and every minute
that we invest in developing AI will
invest another dollar a minute in
developing our own mind and our own
Consciousness I think will be okay
fascinating uh Yvonne Noah Harare thank
you so much honestly a gripping issue
apologies for the interruption